you just want to check out your face is
that what we're doing together shot oh
you just [ __ ] off my glasses we're gonna
have some fun hopefully right that's
Saturday we have no responsibilities
trying to explain your outfit today so
this is an amazing outfit right now here
you ready to go oh so you have a new
outfit on no new you just changed ear
the Pens
I can't stand the cold you ready to go
let's go
so it's been a pretty crazy week for me
my son was off of school and at home and
I was at home and it was hard to manage
him and get all my work done although we
did have a lot of fun on the videos as
you guys probably saw and we crashed out
last night what time I go to bed 10
o'clock 10 o'clock were like we're just
napping on the couch like okay let's
just go to bed and we passed out and
then we woke up way earlier than we
normally do but it's a pretty chill
Saturday and my parents took my son to
Peterborough to go to this Dragon Boat
Festival thing so the house is very
quiet and it's very peaceful relaxing
and we have no responsibilities after
the crazy week that was and so we've
decided we're gonna hop on the Vespa and
go to Senna Island it's not the most
beautiful day but it's relaxing and
we're gonna have some fun so it rained
here last night and I left my best for
outside with the mask on it the helmet
and it got totally soaked inside so now
Nina is going to try to clean it with a
hair dryer like I'm gonna warm blanket
let's go thanks Nina thanks Nina
we got two turkey club sandwiches and we
need to think about time so all I have
is my camera back so you have to figure
out a way to fit all this and I don't
need me not to bring her purse because
it was
you have a joke to tell us no you know
Iver recording I am recording we have a
job to challenge anyone you can tell
everybody how we met
we're going into Mexico yeah we're gonna
go up in there here we go we got you're
just in time
opening up Oh who's this hello
hmm what's your name
imagine meeting you in a place like this
okay we're here at center island get
enough votes Lina's all excited has a
big smile on her face how come cuz I
like nature and that's being outdoors
and I get happy when Nina has a big
happy smile on I'm pretty sure she would
slack off and let me do all the work
okay let's go and try it I'm excited
switching up
don't kill me though okay whatever I
want the one who's telling you wouldn't
do anything for the loop last four
kilometer right are we having a happy
Saturday okay let's go
not meant for people with long legs it's
the funda there's a middle seat I feel
like somebody could sit here yes the
truck is set at the frontier you see the
kids worth it at that okay the child is
not meant to sit there she set up there
really I didn't notice I feel like it's
dangerous to be sitting there I feel
like that's really you don't think
that's right yeah you know how the kid
you know that's why those are seat belts
we buckled we bought does these straps
here that we were using to buckle in our
gear but the Ottoman trust seat belts
for the kids to be saying that right
okay so it is safe
did you bring your bathing suit no well
hold the optional so with Nina gone I
can pull up my iPad and answer your
emails you're all excited that fun you
tired yes
what hurts my butt hurts we're gonna
take the fight back the change for this
thing that was four dollars and fifty
cents and they said do you have fifty
cents we can give you five I said no now
I have all of these coins all of these
coins which I hate having in my wallet
although there's one cool one where's
the cool one that one's pretty cool so
so my default action whenever I get
change is this
bigger baby the change in the piggy bank
yeah Nina has a purse with lots of space
I hate change
they work surprise okay okay so we're
done we're gonna head back we had a
bunch of first today we had our first
visit to center island together we had
our first bicycle rides together our
first quadricycle riding together
Nina's first time to a clothing-optional
Beach so we're gonna catch the ferry get
back to the city
whoa
this guy parked very close did he hit I
think so is that white mark
alright looks like but now but this
would be this is too hot but here maybe
here maybe Wow whatever
next time we got a park at the front of
the sign instead of in the middle all
right let's back that up hey cute stuff
didn't I meet you in Mexico